[Musique]
le trisè point c'est que la réalité du
risque est camouflée à tous les niveaux
hein les banques ont des pertes en
interne très importantes qu'ell ne
montrent pas les les banques centrales
n'exigent pas la transparence les
organismes chargés de faire les audites
en disent encore moins et les directions
générales se tisent dans toutes les
langues donc si nous prenons les
remarques qui viennent d'être faites et
ce contexte bien caractéristique de pas
d'information une volonté farouche des
dirigeants de continuer à à gagner des
fortunes un manque de contrôle et une
hypocrisie générale nous voyons que nous
sommes dans un milieu risqué avec des
acteurs
qui feront des choses contraires à
l'intérêt général
[Musique]